[Music]
the world of sound that is created by so
many musicians is so strong that if you
get goosebumps
we got slaps on your face and punch in
your stomach it's very very intense and
powerful I'm not really able to
translate it into words you just have to
see it my name is Fabio Fognini and I'm
the founder of rocking 1000 the biggest
rock band on earth rocking 1000 is a
band composed of thousands and thousands
of musicians coming from all over the
world we organise massive events where
more than a thousand musicians perform
senior Tennessee we have 400 guitars 250
drummers 300 bassist
350 singers we have a musicians coming
from 30 different countries in the world
from South Korea from the United States
from Canada from Brazil Russia Iran the
logistic challenge is quite big hundreds
and hundreds of people build the stage
which is as big as a football field we
have hundreds of microphones miles and
miles of wires and cables it's crazy all
the musicians have to prepare from home
and once they come here they will have
like three days of rehearsals very
intense days
[Music]
they got to meet each other they started
playing and meld together and build the
magic the main message behind rockin
1000 is the spirit of togetherness the
idea that people that generally play
their big man or sing under the shower
when they're all together they can
really make the difference and it's a
message that goes far beyond music I
think we make no difference of the
sexual orientation political orientation
religious orientations rich or poor
professionals or newbies
we include everybody they're all
together because of rock and roll
[Music]
[Music]
remember protect together every time I
give you a 3/4 breathe on for an attack
on one I put so much love and effort
sweat blood and tears into this band
program we are the best marching band in
the country
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Abraham Duffy jr. and I am
the head your major for the son boom
with us out
we bring something that no other band
brings excitement jaw-dropping
in-your-face entertainment the justice a
drum majors are at the heart of the band
we are known for our showmanship but
what a lot of people don't know is we
teach music to the band we lead the band
we help with formations and we also help
guide the band and the beginning of
August we practice for about 20 hours a
day from 5:00 a.m. to 12:00 a.m. in the
morning you really just have to find
time to sleep not only is it physical
training is also mental and emotional
training as well
there's needed in order to be a part of
a program of our caliber what goes on is
a lot of plane
a lot of plane and a lot of plane and
also marching marching marching marching
marching being a physical shape gives
you endurance it helps you play better
and perform better and also gives you
muscle memory
[Music]
this is my fourth and final year as John
Major my hope for the future of the ban
is to just exhale be better than the
Bands before them be better musicians
just to finally be at the end it's
bittersweet but I am going to lead and
never look back because I know I made my
mind in India you have 700,000 villages
and each village has at least two or
three bends there is no marriage without
a band there is no death without a band
there is no butter without the band and
bands they need instruments roughly 90%
of india's brass band instruments come
from this musical alley jolly Cote Lane
in the city of Meerut very codleyn has
about 100 manufactures but one of the
most renowned is nadir ali company
mr. nadir Lee who was my uncle started
this company in 1885 he were the first
man who started a band in India here is
the first band in 1900 with 24 people it
was immensely liked by the Indian people
and his uncle wasn't the only one with a
passion for the family business
my father's father my father myself and
all my children so you can say the
fourth generation is here
we make brass band musical instruments
like trumpets coordinates fo neom cuba
and also percussion instruments like
drums and things like that you see in
instrument making is an art our
instruments are the best because we use
a system of quality control the most
important thing in making instrument is
the composition of brass the material
quality the instruments from here go to
many countries anywhere from Saudi
Arabia to Germany to France I have
devoted my life and making instruments
music is the elixir of life when you
play and you you concentrate and you
play a good tool or hear a good tune you
think you're out of this world
music is something but you listen to it
and you're lost and you're happy well
amar Stevie Moore I'm generally known is
one of the main pioneers of low fidelity
one-man band on record I've been
recording for 50 something years and
I've made 400 albums in my home
[Music]
and now more rcv more prolific mr.
Stevie more Stevie more yes I am our
Stevie more back when I was a younger
child I started my own idea of home
recording by myself my father was a bass
player doing all the country sessions
with all the stars of Nashville I had
access to tape recorders in my teenage
basement and I was a huge rock and roll
band and absorbed all of these
influences and started messing around
with writing songs and making my own
music do you record the privacy of your
own home is that correct that's right
now how do you do that well late sixties
is when I started making my little
albums I / dub all the instruments
myself I play bass and guitars and
keyboards and percussion and vocals I
got really good at it I've deduced seven
eight nine ten overdubs and you'd still
hear the very first thing that I used
did you invent home recording of course
not but I took it to another level
long before it was customary I've
probably written about four or five
thousand songs they came out
effortlessly I would compile the most
recent songs I wouldn't pick and choose
the best ones and throw the worst ones
on the floor and that's been my
aesthetic all along it's like everything
is released warts and all because bad
music is brilliant it's a diary of sound
everybody that has ever been a record
collector loves to turn their pals on
the obscure why do you hear this one I
mean I do have that reputation talking
heads and b-52s and we're all fans of
mine naturally a lot of these big
artists have found my music just word of
mouth but they never saw me because I
was the home hermit
she's doing more of it I filled up the
quantity without thinking about starting
over at the beginning to improve the
quality I've hardly ever performed and I
was a bedroom guy it was always get home
put the headphones on and then I would
work for hours and hours in 2010 things
started to explode out of nowhere
suddenly I was in a band and touring the
world
I was playing hard rock shows big
festivals and tiny dives is incredible
my career really started taking off a
little too late in life often people say
I can't see how you've done this same
thing all this time without falling
through the trap and by avoiding the
mainstream nobody is gonna dare tell me
what I can and can't do feel so good to
have that integrity intact I'm proud of
all that and I'm also still a little kid
you
[Music]